We are gonna make some pickled veggies.
Apple cider vinegar that I tried to make. Did not turn out so well.
Amazing sprouts brand cucumber onions.
The exact same thing for both pickled onions and pickled cucumbers.
Oh my god.
I always just guess with the apple cider vinegar.
That's probably enough.
Apple cider vinegar is the one
specifically that helps with blood sugar regulation.
Also amazing for stimulating bile production,
which if you have digestive issues, it's amazing.
I add peppercorns
it off with some clean water.
Just fill it to the top.
Not using tap water
for some lids on 48 hours at least is when it's gonna be like the best.